when I started we were very small stores
size of garages and I'd have one person
in the store that was the leader of the
store and they would have two and three
workers those people were generally
comfortable with things they knew how to
be in control of things contrast that
the kinkos up today open 24 hours a day
seven days a week 40 50 workers the
leader today needs to know a lot about
people now if you don't have a balanced
life where work love and player and
balance you're trying to if you don't
have that you can't run a
twenty-four-hour-a-day business you
gotta bring yourself out I saw it happen
all the time and nobody wants to follow
a leader that's tired Haggard miserable
and so our business was so intoxicating
for the managers and the people in it
that they really had a rough time
leaving and so we encourage people have
a balanced life because I know that I
noticed a lot of people aren't business
really burn themselves out by
overworking and let's throw out that
word balance we're always trying to say
balance and it's like that a big deal
what is that that is a word I would like
to see eradicated from the cultural
conversation I mean you can't open a
magazine today right without somebody
the headline is always how so-and-so
found balance you know how this person
compounds like have you ever met a
person first of all and if you did would
you want to even be friends with them is
that somebody who you would want to call
in the middle of the night when you've
lost your balance balance is something
that you'd find and lose regain and who
lose we're on a planet that's spending
seven thousand miles an hour our minds
are spending twenty thousand miles an
hour we're surrounded by people who are
in change we're and change to expect
that you should somehow be able to hold
your state through that entire thing is
just crazy thank you guys so much for
watching I made this series because I
wanted to promote understanding and
awareness I wanted you to see that it's
not always looking at it as one thing or
the other but if you embrace the genius
of the end and bring those two seemingly
opposite points of view together that
that is where the true genius lies I
want you to see that you
learn from both of the people that are
profiled in the video especially
probably from the person who you don't
immediately agree with if you can
understand their perspective and apply
it to your life chances are it will help
you get to where you want to go a lot
faster so let me know what you think
leave a comment below I'll join the
discussion continued to believe and I'll
see you soon